اليوم نحبك تخاطبي وجدان صباح العربيه
وتسمعينا شي صوتك مسمعكم شو بدنا نسمعكم
شو بتحبوا في شي معين
بقلكم مقطع من العمل اللي قدمناه ليله
من جبران ايضا بالمحكيه بيت بالمحكيه مش
معروف كتير انه هو لجبران خليل جبران
بيقول
عيني
يموت لن
محلى
الوباء
بالواما وما
احلل
عايزه بيه
هو يلا
[موسيقى]
وتحومي
ليل
وادي
وبعمل
زنودي
جاسك
لا هيا
[موسيقى]
الواد اتحامل يعني بس يطلع الضباب فوق
الوادي
العزوبيه ايوه
رح نسمع كمان وحده بس
اوكي طيب اذا في دقيقتين في عنا كمان
حابين هيك نشبع منك ونسمع كمان بدون اسئله
خلاص يعني بنغني شو بدنا نغني رح اغني لكم
مقطع من ايدياف بالفرنسيه والعربيه كمان
منعمل انا قدمته ديفا جاهزه ام كلثوم لانه
كمان انتو حكيتوا عن ترجمه النصوص من
اللغات الاجنبيه الى العربيه
نو
ضر يا
نوجان رقرت نيلوبياكم
[موسيقى]
ولا
شيء
لا ما بندم
عشير
كنا
بالماضي
وارجعت حفياني
[موسيقى]
من الذكريات
جمعه تغمار
وقت اتخطب للنار جرار الضحك والاه
وحزننا اللي بالاسرار
بحياتها قصص الحب
نهدي الطريق
[موسيقى]
القلب ارميت الزمان بعيد وراح
بلش من جديد
[موسيقى]
لا ولا شيء لا ما بندم على الشيء الى اخره
الله يسلم ها شكرا